we spoke with Ian Bremmer of the Eurasia
group earlier and he said externally it
looks like Vladimir Putin is on
dangerous grounds that he is being
pressured by economic sanctions but
internally he still has a grip on the
public is this going to last long for
him
that's exactly right he definitely still
has a grip the question is how long will
that last right because if you think
about it the depreciation of the ruble
will both shocked Russians particularly
what they've seen over the last couple
of days will affect those Russians that
travel abroad that's only about let's
say a fifth of them but by spring of
next year we'll be affecting everyone
because it's going to lead to
double-digit inflation because Russians
are so dependent on imported goods so
President Putin will be very concerned
about the depreciation of the ruble he's
still safe he's probably safe for a very
long time he has very high ratings
however the people around him could be
sacrificed and we're already even today
starting to see a bit of a fight between
various people in the president's inner
circle something and I watched Russian
politics on a daily basis we haven't
seen in years
the knives have already come out people
blaming one another for the depreciation
of the ruble it's any of this by any
chance going to make him back down from
Ukraine or from sanctions is any of this
gonna actually weaken him or make him
back down that's a good question if I do
the answer to that I'm sure the
Ukrainians would want to hear it I don't
know that to be the case I think you
know what we're seeing will definitely
give him pause right I mean the
sanctions were one thing
many Russians sort of shrugged them off
then the oil price started to decline
and that was much more concerning and
now we seem to be in this space this
nexus where there's a real crisis of
confidence in general in what the
Russian government is doing and that
might temper what he does in current
Ukraine it's entirely possible
Russia's Parliament's gonna meet on
Thursday so Ryan what might we expect
you know I think the blame game will
continue so today we have the head of
Rose Neff that's Russia's largest oil
company blaming members of the political
opposition and a former finance
a gentleman named Alexei Kudrin who was
still very close very close to the
Russian president blaming them for
criticising a bond sale that Rose Smith
carried out yesterday calling them
calling it a provocation that rose Neff
may have been involved with the
depreciation of the ruble or done
something that would contribute to that
we've also got talk that perhaps the
Prime Minister could be replaced so I
think on Thursday look nobody's jobs
safe the central bank's heads jobs going
to be on the line and probably several
others